aujourd'hui j'ai envie de parler de
l'expression vouloir croire mais qui est
un truc qu'on dit finalement très
souvent tu te cause qui parle de boli
finb auliffe croyance veut avoir
et parfois c'est plus subtil que ça
c'est des croyances qui traîne et qui on
a l'impression que c'est normal de les
avoir et que ça serait insensé de
d'avoir ses croyances
alors qu'il s'agit de croyance empirique
après sur l'état du monde qui devrait
évoluer en fonction des circonstances
mais surtout la notion de vouloir croire
quelque chose est assez étrange à bien y
réfléchir le monde il est tel qu'il est
et ce que l'on pense de l'état du monde
ne devrait pas dépendre de ce qu'on veut
croire de l'état du monde
il s'agit d'une certaine manière d'une
violation de la guillotine de fioul
inversée donc j'avais parlé dans cet
épisode précédent one présente soleil
ces premières et ce qui est assez
étrange c'est que la notion de vouloir
croire finalement c'est quelque chose
qui est très respecté très qui se peut
paraître très respectable n'est pas
choqué quand quelqu'un dit pendant que
je veux croire en l'humanité
veux veux croire que l'éducation 20
marchés où je veux croire qu' il existe
quelque chose de prendre un temps moment
bien chaque humain c'est assez
problématique je trouve que cette notion
de vouloir croire soit devenu quelque
chose de respectable et de passer tout à
fait légitimes à priori à défendre alors
qu en fait d'un point de vue
épistémologique c'est complètement
erroné
en tout cas si on en croit la formule de
bayes bas ce qu'on veut croire n'a
aucune influence sur ce qui peut croire
puisque ce qu'il faut croire qu'après la
formule de base c'est le résultat du
calcul de la formule de baines et si on
a d'autres philosophies épistémologique
comme la méthode scientifique et où en
général
essayez de biaiser les résultats pour
que ce qu'on est amené à croire qu à ce
monde à ceux qui voulaient croire c'est
quand même très mal vu dans la plupart d
épistémologie car il me semble que c'est
quelque chose de beau qui devra être
totalement
rejeté par toute approche empirique du
savoir et même par toute approche
empirique d'ailleurs finalement c'est
une vidéo avec un mais ça arrive
extrêmement simple il serait sans doute
bon de réfléchir à la validité de cette
idée de vouloir quoi et deux voies en
fait que vouloir croire c'est en fait un
énorme défaut c'est ce qui ouvre la
porte aux raisonnements au motiver et à
la rationalisation
or le raisonnement motivés et la
rationalisation c'est sans doute le
principal biais cognitif en tout cas le
viol collectif qui est le plus qui a le
plus d'influencé sur ce qu'on met
vraiment en finalement amené à croire et
c'est également l'une des raisons pour
lesquelles les débats se passe si
souvent si mal en pratique tout cas
quand il s'agit d'une question empirique
qu'on cherche à savoir ce qu'il serait
adéquat de croire et bien la notion de
valeur croît ressemble absolument à côté
de la plaque il semble qu'il faudrait
elle a rejeté une chose très importante
a noté
si vous êtes déjà convaincu par ce
message c'est le fait que nier
l'importance de ce qu'on veut croire
dans ce qu'il faut croire est quelque
chose qui en fait extrêmement difficile
en pratique et si on y réfléchit pas de
façon inconsciente
on va être amené à utiliser ce qu'on
veut croire pour en arriver à la
conclusion sur ce qu on est amené à
croire est typiquement ça peut prendre
plein de formes un peu subtile et varié
qui dès qu'on a tendance à dire quand on
est dans une situation on est confronté
un truc qu'on ne veut pas croire mais
tendance à se dire ok c'est bien plus
qu'à donner tout ça mais est-ce que je
suis moralement obligé de croire ça et
rien que le fait de se poser cette
question est-ce que je suis obligé de
croire ça souvent ça cache un peu un
raisonnement motivés et derrière cette
notion de vouloir croire qui en fait est
la raison pour laquelle ou pose la
question est-ce que je suis obligé de
croire ce la même chose parfois on
essaie de s'ouvrir la porte à une
certaine croyance du coup on se
demandait ce que néanmoins je peux
croire quelque chose pareille lorsqu on
se demande si on peut croire quelque
chose c'est probablement que derrière il
y a un raisonnement motiver ses côtés
derrière un raisonnement motivés qui a
et du coup probablement néfaste à la
qualité de notre réflexion sur ce qu'il
faudrait croire
enfin il ya peut-être d'autres variantes
subtil à
de se vouloir croire qu'ils sont
également utiles à avoir en tête par
exemple le fait que bien souvent ce
n'est pas tant le fait que l'on veut y
croire quelque chose qui fasse que on le
met en avant et qu'on a amené à dire
telle ou telle chose mais bien souvent
en fait il ya des choses qu'on ne peut
pas se permettre de reconnaître
publiquement en tout cas que l'on croit
typiquement il ya plein de sujets dans
laquelle le sait juste pas respectable
par exemple d'avoir tel ou tel pensées
et il peut y avoir du coup certaines
formes de censure par les autres ou
d'auto censure ou parce qu'on fait
partie d'un certain une telle communauté
où tous les membres de cette communauté
croit par exemple qu'il faut penser
d'une certaine manière on a tendance à
hésiter à notre cas pas faire l'effort
de réflexion pour vraiment questionner
nos croyances et du cou finalement nos
croyances devienne la croyance de la
communauté avec elle on appartient
pour être un peu concret je vous donner
un exemple de ça c'est le prime de
l'éducation pendant longtemps voilà je
suis dans une communauté de gens qui
sont fans d'éducation aux services
vocaux éducation et pendant longtemps je
voyais beaucoup l'éducation comme étant
la chose prioritaire le truc qu'il faut
améliorer
et si on arrive à améliorer sa série où
tous les autres auprès de la société
c'est une position qui était la crosse
de ma communauté et dire que ça étant
donné ce que je fais et étant donné que
je fais partie de cette communauté
consciemment ou non by m'étais jamais
venu à l'idée de questionner le rôle de
l'éducation pendant longtemps et bomba
récemment si vous avez suivi un peu nos
discussions notamment avec thibault
surre axiome où la discussion présente
que j'ai eu avec michael n launay ou
encore l'interview avec absolue
bah en fait j'ai complètement changé de
position par rapport à ça et en
particulier au niveau de l'éducation en
mathématiques
je pense qu'en fait voilà c'est pas être
pas la priorité aujourd'hui d'augmenter
à l'éducation en mathématiques pour des
raisons qui sont à voir avec notamment
avec la crise efficace le fait que ce
soit c'est en fait quelque chose de très
difficile à l'améliorer en effet ça
serait super si tu mon été
très très à l'aise avec la forme de gaz
par exemple mais en pratique c'est juste
ultra couteau dedans passer par
l'éducation et il ya sans doute d'autres
voix qui sont beaucoup plus prioritaire
ouais c'était une courte vidéo ici à
bâle feeder cars en suisse dont les
alpes suisses qui sont quand même
absolument magnifique c1 qui 360° et je
vous invite du coup à réfléchir à ce que
vous voulez croire et si finalement ce
n'est pas quelque chose de néfaste
le fait que vous vouliez croire ce que
vous voulez croire